hey Gwendolyn how are you hi I'm so well
it's a pleasure to see you how are you
doing I am doing great I love this show
so much I'm a huge fan of The Adams
Family I dress up as Wednesday Adams
pretty much every year uh and I'm a
full-on adult and I do that
um I just wanted to know your whole
experience with this what is the very
first memory you have of The Addams
Family I seem to remember the black and
white TV series of The Addams Family
being shown on television in the UK and
that would have been in the
80s or 90s I was still quite young and I
just felt these characters were unlike
anything I'd ever seen before I loved
the idea of taking sort of ghoulish like
people ghoulish characters and then
putting them in a home setting and
seeing how many similarities there are
between those people that feel at such a
distance with the rest of us and so also
first as someone that's always felt like
an outsider it was really heartwarming
to me to see something that felt like a
more realistic representation of life
than most cookie cutter more average
depictions of uh of society on
television
I know exactly what you mean you know
speaking of Outsiders who completely own
it that is a perfect way of describing
Wednesday Adams what are you excited for
the fans to see when it comes to this
version Jenna Ortega's version I think
that Jenna is truly exceptional in this
role she does a really incredible job
and she is an actress of great
capability and great dynamism and really
extraordinary force she is an incredible
force and she brings her own inimitable
fresh take on Wednesday and we see more
of Wednesday than we've ever seen before
who in The Addams Family was always a
character I was captivated by I wanted
to know more about her I wanted to see
into her world and see what she was
doing the thought she was thinking
um I love that it's focused on a young
woman finding her way in the world I
love as um I play Larissa Weems the
principal of the Nevermore Academy and I
love their relationship I don't think
that's a relationship you off often see
on television two Outsiders women who
are entirely different distant ages and
yet they are forced to be together come
together work together through all of
their complexities and there's a great
intensity in the relationship that
really volleys from Pure unadulterated
hatred to something that is akin to a
weird sort of love and obsession
I know I loved seeing their relationship
evolve like that that was such a
highlight for me and I just love
Nevermore Academy Wednesday's working on
solving a mystery throughout this series
if you had to solve a murder mystery
with one person the cast who would it be
who would you rely on
I think that if I had to solve a mystery
I would want to solve it with well Jenna
would be incredibly detail-orientated
and she would really rat out the
situation she would not let it lie she
would shine a torch into every dark
corner of of the world of the situation
and it would be resolved she would be
relentless in her solving of it
um and a very good fun and hugely
charismatic and endearing along the way
I love that okay and something that was
such a treat for the fans knowing that
Christina Ricci is obviously a part of
this series playing Wednesday Adams in
the 90s films a teacher at Nevermore
Academy what's it like having her
support and just having her on set she's
truly wonderful Christina she's such an
icon you know she has an incredible body
of work I obviously loved her so much
and was really just
captivated by this incredible actress
that was inhabiting the character
Wednesday Adams you know in such a
perfect way and she's had an
extraordinary career and really done
some some really
um fabulously out there work as well as
in a more mainstream context as well
um so it was a big big admirer of her
work she is a hoot and A real blast and
I had such a great time and we are now
friends and uh it was a dream it was a
true dream but I couldn't believe it
though our first day on set I was quite
I had did have to pinch myself I
couldn't believe I was working with
Christina Rishi
I love that you're as big of a fan as we
are yeah I really am though I just
adored The Adams Family and I also never
thought I'd get to be a part of it I
really didn't
um so I'm I'm delighted I'm very very
grateful